what about on the animal side
the ones that uh figured out how to move
efficiently is there anything you find
inspiring or beautiful
in the movement of anybody i do have a
favorite example okay
so it sort of goes with the passive
walking idea so is there
you know how energy efficient are
animals okay there's a great series of
experiments
by george lotter at harvard and mike
tranafilo at mit
they were studying fish swimming in a
water tunnel
okay and one of these the type of fish
they were studying
were these rainbow trout because they
there was a
phenomenon well understood that rainbow
trout when they're swimming upstream at
mating season
they kind of hang out behind the rocks
and it looks like i mean that's tiring
work swimming upstream
they're hanging out behind the rocks
maybe there's something energetically
interesting there
so they tried to recreate that they put
in this water tunnel
a rock basically a cylinder that had the
same sort of
vortex street the eddies coming off the
back of the rock that you would see in a
stream
and they put a real fish behind this and
watched how it swims
and the amazing thing is that if you
watch from above
what the fish swims when it's not behind
a rock it has a particular gate
you can identify the fish the same way
you look at a human looking
walking down the street you sort of have
a sense of how human walks
the fish has a characteristic gate you
put that fish behind the rock
its gate changes and what
they saw was that it was actually
resonating and kind of
surfing between the vortices yeah
now here was the experiment that really
was the clincher because there was still
it wasn't clear how much of that was
mechanics of the fish how much of that
is control
the brain so the clincher experiment and
maybe one of my favorites to date
although there are
many good experiments they took
they this was now a dead fish um
they took a dead fish they put a string
that went
that tied the mouse of the fish to the
rock so it couldn't go back and get
caught in the grates and then they asked
what would that dead fish do
when it was hanging out behind the rock
and so what you'd expect it sort of
flopped around like a dead fish
in the in the vortex wake until
something sort of amazing happens and
this video
is worth putting in
right what happens uh the dead fish
basically starts swimming upstream
right it's completely dead no brain
no motors no control but it somehow the
mechanics of the fish resonate with the
vortex street and it starts swimming
upstream
it's one of the best examples ever who
do you get credit
for that too is that just evolution
constantly
just figuring out by killing a lot of
generations of
animals uh like the most efficient
motion
is that uh or maybe the physics of our
world
completely like it's like evolution
applied not only to animals but just the
entirety of it somehow
drives to efficiency like nature likes
efficiency
i don't know if that question even makes
any sense i understand the question
that's reason
i mean do they co-evolve yeah somehow
yeah like i don't know if an environment
can evolve
but um i mean there are experiments
that people do careful experiments that
show that um
animals can adapt to unusual situations
and recover efficiency
so there seems like at least in one
direction i think
there is reason to believe that the
animals motor system
and probably its mechanics uh adapt
in order to be more efficient but
efficiency isn't the only goal of course
sometimes it's too easy to think about
only efficiency but we have to do a lot
of other things
first not get eaten and then
all other things being equal try to save
energy
you